[Música]
en Perú el nuevo gobierno declaró el
estado de emergencia durante 60 días en
siete provincias en un intento por
controlar las protestas por el proceso
contra el destituido presidente Pedro
Castillo son varios los fallecidos en
las movilizaciones al tiempo que el ex
jefe de estado envió una contundente
carta desde prisión ampliamos desde Lima
el presidente Nicolás Maduro felicitó a
las delegaciones del gobierno colombiano
y la guerrilla del eln que finalizaron
su primer ciclo de conversaciones
llevado a cabo en Caracas los
negociadores indicaron que se prevé que
la siguiente fase del proceso se lleve a
cabo en México
en Chile el congreso acordó una nueva
hoja de ruta para el proceso
Constituyente tras más de tres meses de
negociaciones en principio se creará un
nuevo órgano redactor llamado consejo
constitucional con integrantes elegidos
por la ciudadanía y 24 congresistas que
participarán como expertos ampliamos
desde Santiago
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos con
la tensa situación que vive Perú tras la
declaración de estado de emergencia en
siete provincias varios muertos en las
protestas contra el gobierno de Dina
boluarte decenas de policías heridos en
medio de choques en las manifestaciones
y la contundente carta enviada por el
destituido presidente Pedro Castillo
desde prisión donde califica boluarte de
Usurpadora desde Lima Francisco Zacarías
nos amplió detalles de la situación
el gobierno de la presidenta Dina
boluarte decretó el estado de emergencia
por 60 días en siete provincias de la
región Apurímac han sido suspendidos
algunos derechos constitucionales para
que las fuerzas de seguridad puedan
poner orden y frenar los actos de
vandalismo que llevan ya siete muertos a
lo largo de estas jornadas según la
defensoría del pueblo alrededor de 15
policías resultaron heridos después de
un ataque con explosivos por parte de
vándalos que piden la libertad del
expresidente Pedro Castillo la renuncia
de la presidenta Dina boluarte y el
cierre del Congreso lo de bordes
violentos de hoy bloquearon tramos de la
carretera Panamericana tomaron un
aeropuerto incendiaron una fiscalía una
comisaría y secuestraron a dos policías
en Lima fueron atacadas las
instalaciones de Panamericana televisión
América Televisión y el canal n los
manifestantes también atacaron a una
unidad móvil de radio exitosa por su
parte el ministro del interior César
Cervantes afirmó que hay 24 400 personas
involucradas en las protestas en todo el
Perú y elevó la cifra de policía heridos
a 44 el ministro Cervantes reveló que se
evalúa la presencia física de las
fuerzas armadas en las calles bajo el
comando de la presidenta Dina boluarte
para intentar poner orden a la situación
el lunes 12 de diciembre finalizó en
Venezuela el primer ciclo de
conversaciones entre el gobierno
colombiano y la guerrilla del eln las
negociaciones fueron retomadas en
noviembre de este año y pretenden
finalizar un conflicto de casi 60 años
por su parte El Ejecutivo de México
confirmó su disposición para realizar
una segunda fase en su país a principios
de 2023 Andrés triviño nos cuenta más
como una luz de Esperanza así
describieron el gobierno de Colombia y
la guerrilla del eln la finalización del
primer ciclo de negociaciones en su
intento por lograr un acuerdo de paz
definitivo entre las dos partes luego de
21 días de reuniones a Puerta cerrada
acordaron cuatro puntos incluyendo el
reconocimiento de la grave situación de
violencia en los territorios y atención
de emergencia en departamentos como el
Valle del cauca y chocó las partes
reconocen la grave situación de
violencia que se presenta en los
territorios Y decidieron poner en
ejecución un acuerdo parcial de atención
de emergencias que iniciará a partir de
enero del 2023 las conversaciones de
Park reiniciaron el pasado 21 de
noviembre en Caracas con la intención de
finalizar un conflicto de casi seis
décadas el primer acercamiento se
realizó en el 2017 durante el gobierno
de Juan Manuel Santos pero fue
suspendido en el 2019 durante el mandato
de Iván Duque luego de que el perpetuará
un ataque que dejó a 22 policías muertos
el apoyo internacional ha jugado un
papel crucial en estas nuevas
negociaciones recientemente los
gobiernos de México y chile se sumaron a
Cuba Noruega y Venezuela como garantes
mientras que Alemania Suecia Suiza y
España son acompañantes el respaldo que
recibe esta mesa por parte de la
comunidad internacional es muy
importante Nosotros le hemos dicho que
lo agradecemos Y como dice su palabra
nos acompañan y nos reemplazan los
esfuerzos de los colombianos para que
esta tarea de la paz recaiga ese nombre
de las dos delegaciones por su parte el
gobierno mexicano confirmó que la
próxima Ronda de negociaciones se
realizará en su país a partir de enero
en las cuales se espera lograr un cese
al fuego bilateral
y continuando con temas que involucran a
Colombia y a Venezuela el presidente
Nicolás Maduro anunció que a partir del
primero de enero de 2023 la frontera
entre ambas naciones quedará
completamente abierta para permitir el
paso de vehículos particulares lo que no
ocurre desde 2015 maduro informó además
que actualmente están ultimando
preparativos para cumplir todo lo
acordado con su homólogo Gustavo Petro
desde agosto
puedo anunciar
Que estaremos abriendo completamente la
frontera
de todo el occidente de Venezuela con
Colombia para cumplir la palabra
empeñada con el presidente Gustavo Petro
de aperturarla el primero de enero
empezando el año 2023 para que esa
fronteras queden bueno
funcionales libres en Chile tras meses
de negociaciones El Congreso acordó la
creación de un nuevo órgano redactor
para la nueva constitución que busca
acabar con la heredada de la dictadura
en una segunda oportunidad luego de que
la convención constitucional redactara
un borrador de Carta Magna que fue
rechazado en consulta popular a la
ciudadanía desde Santiago Patricia Luna
corresponsal de France 24 nos dio los
detalles
98 días después de que los chilenos
acudieran de forma masiva un plebiscito
Y rechazaran de forma contundente con un
62% una nueva propuesta constitucional
destinada a reemplazar a la polémica
Constitución de Augusto pinochet que
Data en el país desde 1980 la mayoría de
los partidos que forman parte del
Congreso chileno presentaron en la noche
de este lunes un acuerdo y
constitucional y un nuevo itinerario
para una nueva propuesta constitucional
se trataría de un consejo constitucional
formado por 50 miembros elegidos por
sufragio universal de forma paritaria
con voto obligatorio en unas elecciones
que si se cumplen itinerario estarían
previstas en abril de 2023 al que le
precedería una comisión de expertos
formado por 24 miembros 12 elegidos por
la cámara de diputados y 12 por el
senado que tendría como trabajo elaborar
un anteproyecto sobre el que luego
trabajaría este consejo constitucional
al que se sumaría también la comisión de
expertos y se los brazos en seis meses
este órgano debería proponer un nuevo
texto constitucional que se basa en 12
puntos previos ya acordados que deben de
cumplirse y que marcan una serie de
normas básicas y debería estar
aproximadamente si los plazos son
cumplidos en octubre de 2023 a partir de
ahí un mes más tarde se convocaría a un
nuevo plebiscito de salida también con
voto obligatorio en lo que sería ese
segundo intento de reemplazar la
polémica Constitución de Augusto
pinochet que Data todavía en el país y
sigue vigente vamos ahora sí porque
entre lágrimas el presidente electo Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva recibió el diploma
que lo acredita como ganador de las
presidenciales el próximo mandatario
condenó lo que llamó el legado perverso
de Yahir bolsonaro y destacó la valentía
de las autoridades electorales para
defender la democracia pese a las
amenazas y ofensas de los bolsonaristas
Lula ASUME el cargo del próximo primero
de y así se pronunció en su discurso de
aceptación
Haré todo lo posible junto con mi
querido colega geraldo alkmin
para cumplir con el compromiso que
asumimos solo durante la campaña sino a
lo largo de toda mi vida para ser de
Brasil un país más desarrollado y más
justo
con garantía de dignidad y calidad de
vida para todos los brasileños
especialmente para las personas más
necesitadas
la policía de Bahamas arrestó a San Bang
pan Frida el fundador y ex presidente
ejecutivo de eft una de las firmas más
grandes de criptomonedas que se declaró
en quiebra en uno de los colapsos de
mayor perfil en la industria
criptográfica la fiscalía general
estadounidense reveló a su vez que
entregó a Bahamas notificación formal de
cargos criminales contra El joven de 30
años que ya ha negado haber cometido
fraude y que podría solicitar su
extradición FX Se declaró en quiebra en
noviembre después de que sus
inversionistas retiraran millones de
dólares en apenas tres días tras salir a
flote una crisis de liquidez que según
la justicia habría sido originada por
desvíos de dinero de bankman hacia otras
de sus empresas
así llegamos al final de esta
informativa ustedes Gracias por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros
[Música]